it's a very strange question honestly
for me but i would want to marry
somebody that i see building i if i'm
with my boyfriend now and i see
marrying him one day if we get to that
point because he is a good partner he
helps me do certain things and i help
him and i
i would it's easier to live life with
somebody
but that's not like my end goal like i'm
not gonna put everything on the side so
i can like live life with someone but
you know when you're grocery shopping
it's nice to do it with someone i don't
know if that answer so your answer is
like look i'm going to be a good partner
i'm going to bring my i like i like i'm
going to bring something to the table
but you're going to bring something to
the table but we're going to do this
together yeah and also like i always
like him and i currently like we
uh things that he's good at
i'm not and vice versa and also like i
totally agree a woman should be able to
make a home because guys don't really
know how to make a home yeah they don't
know how to how to decorate the
apartment they don't know the flowers
are nice in the apartment they don't
know that like your utensils should
match and [__] so like
you know i'm guilty of all that by the
way um ally why would a man or why did
your husband want to marry you
why wouldn't he marry me no i'm kidding
so it's basically
my perspective on marriage is a little
bit interesting
being in that feminine role where i
fully depend on my husband i believe
that gives him purpose so i think that
he's had a greater sense of appreciation
for the work that he does so it's more
fulfilling and he can cope with the
stress more because well you know he's
doing it for me and he's coming home to
me also i make sure that he's rewarded
for his hard work and his efforts he
pretty much can lean on me in times of
trouble but also we can also enjoy each
other in times of great joy and that's
that's a really fun thing a lot of
people don't know this my husband was a
50 year old bachelor mm-hmm about 48
year old bachelor when i met him so he
he tells me even now that i add value to
his life and when i think about marriage
as a business it's like
drum it incorporated how can i make our
our brand our family our business how
can i make it so that we can thrive how
much bigger can we make this drum and
household name and that's my approach to
marriage so i if if you want a really
good hard worker as your wife like
that's what i think i bring together um
one follow-up question before we get to
pearl
you said your husband when you met him
he was 48 yes and now he's 50. so you've
been married give or take two years
together two years was he successful
before he met you
oh i think he was very successful oh yes
yes i hung out at the finish line and i
got a winner
but that's a thing
i do think it's a thing and so eric can
you turn me up a little bit i'm down a
little bit
so when i met him he was very
accomplished in the military that's the
thing is a lot of women wouldn't think
that my husband makes enough money but
i'm a badge bunny i'm like a masculinity
honey that's what i'm looking for what
is a badge money a badge money is a
woman who likes cops firefighters
service members so a man in uniform yes
yes a man in uniform so he's a major and
he's got all these shiny medals and i'm
like sir
sir pick me marry me choose me
and yeah so i know that a lot of women
wouldn't think that he makes enough but
we live in the midwest so it's like more
than enough money to go around and then
you know i've got the muscles to make up
for it so
um all right pearl why would a man want
to marry you
um i i do my best to be an asset in a
guy's life in whatever way that i can so
with my last boyfriend i was always like
cooking and cleaning um and i'd like
manage some of his business stuff
so when i when i'm like going into a
relationship i just want to i always
think about like what can i do to help
this guy like
his life be easier day-to-day i think
that's what every part you should every
if you're in a partnership you should
always try to
find
i feel like i'm something yeah some guy
eric if you can hear me is the volume
that's a train yeah okay but so we're
good on the volume we're good okay
gotcha because we all seem to sound a
little low yeah all of us so i don't
know if you can turn that up
as you were
i'm sorry what what how did you finish i
forgot i was just saying that i think
it's important to be an asset to a guy's
life yeah i i definitely agree with
women being in a relationship and you
don't have i'm definitely not for
splitting bill bills and all that but
you need to contribute you need to be
of value but not just in a relationship
in in life like if you
if you're with a partner you should do
stuff together like okay maybe he's
cooking you said you were cooking and
cleaning was he doing anything or he was
just um
there
no he was he was doing other things okay
well can i can i go follow up with you
yeah and you tell me yo hey that's too
personal hey i don't know i want to go
there but
you know allie married the guy that she
was dating
coco plans on marrying i guess the guy
that you're dating that's something you
envisioned but you were being an asset
to your relationship
cooking cleaning being an asset but you
didn't end up marrying him so is that
like
you know i kind of was bringing being
the asset but it didn't work out so i
kind of regret it um no i don't i don't
regret that no um
i mean
i think i could have had that if i want
i just didn't see it long term um so did
you break up with him or he broke up
with you
oh you ended up yeah i just didn't see
it long term um and i was i just i think
a lot of girls waste their 20s with guys
that are like boyfriends and not
husbands and i just didn't want to do
that
um so yeah i ended that but i don't
regret doing that because i think one it
gave me like relationship skills so i
understand a little bit better like how
i can help a guy in the future let's
talk about this girls wasting their 20s
okay and how old are you by the way i'm
25. you're 25 yes you are 27 20 coco 31
31 okay so you guys are in mid-20s early
30s
um i've been very vocal about this i'll
as a guy waste your 20s as much as you'd
like your 20s are your time to [__] up
make mistakes do stupid stuff date the
wrong girl
as a guy
it's you're able to do that as a girl
you can do that in your early 20s you do
not want to do that in your late 20s
okay
um
let's talk about that why is it
important for a girl to actually
not waste their 20s well your value
decreases as a woman the older you get
and your opportunity to give a man
children um it's less and less the older
you get yeah you can have
ivf but most guys don't want to spend
like what is it 30k
16k 16k yeah work most of the time yeah
so i mean if a guy can pick you know a
35 year old woman or a 25 year old woman
he's going to pick the 25 year old woman
you think so yeah why because of the
ability to be fertile yeah partially and
like men
they surveyed men between the ages of
like 20 and 80 and all of them
prefer girls around the age of 22 23.
yeah this is what rola was saying sexual
sexual marketplace so um i mean i think
there's other sexual market value i
don't want to mess that up yeah i mean i
think there's other things that come
into play but i think men when it comes
to building a family and you also have
the issue of you know the more
relationships that a girl has been and
the more traumatized she's going to be
the more she the more access she has to
complain about yeah and that just
happens the older you get well let me
let me actually give you a different
side of the coin because i remember you
were very um
open about this you said you are so much
better of a woman as a female as a
girlfriend at 30 31 as you were at 24.
yeah explain why i feel in your 20s you
just you're starting to learn who you
are and you see what you like when you
dislike and
i think that in your 20s
you shouldn't be dating somebody
like if you're 21 22 you should not be
in a relationship for like five years
i think you should if it happens great
good for you but i think that you should
explore who you are as a person and by
that you can also date multiple guys so
you can see what you like what you're
dislike so you think that a woman who's
21 22 she gets out of college she should
go through her whole face
never said that i said it you did
no i never said you should go through a
whole face you said date multiple guys
so i did not say it has to be oh but we
know what i mean i think you should
live your life
and see who you are so then later